kourtney kardashian and penelope disick
the mother-daughter duo we never knew we
always needed on tic tac i'm just like
living life their account titled p and
court hit the social media platform last
month
and since then p's dad scott disick has
even gotten in on the fun oh steven
there's one more thing i have to mention
what is it
i love you bye
so has court's fiance travis barker
[Music]
the eldest kardashian sister and her
nine-year-old daughter posted that clip
on saturday twirling around the kitchen
with the blink 182 drummer that could be
really cute and while the newly engaged
couple took a beat to engage in a little
pda pee kept on twirling i love it
penelope also teamed up with our
soon-to-be step-sister travis's 15 year
old daughter alabama alabama invited p
to do a joint tick-tock last week after
a fan requested it okay okay
but back to court and penelope in
between all the mommy daughter
lip-syncing
[Music]
the two have treated fans to beauty
tutorials home tours and some seriously
yummy campfire moments
[Music]
and get this court sister kim kardashian
and her daughter north just followed
suit and joined tick-tock too you know
social media is such a great tool and
kim despite what she said in the past i
just don't dance okay i make money moves
right she's dancing people okay holy
spirit activate oh no holy spirit
activate holy spirit activate activate
activate all right let's go the 41 year
old reality star joined the social media
platform over the weekend with an
account called kim and north
and they've already served up some
seriously cute mother-daughter collabs
[Music]
whether they are singing dancing or just
showing off some at-home antics
[Music]
it seems like the business mogul is on
track to make tick-tock her latest
social media triumph
[Music]
got any grapes
you